[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go HB Tony trim yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah start the show start the show
don't trip yep
I was tired that's fine yeah yeah yeah
another episode of Hanson ramify guys
I'm your Hannibal Burres co-host Tony
TransAm rufio what's up man
what's up dawg Rufio brought his own
critter at guitar a piano I'm Shane I
pulled up i watch the show I'm a big
supporter that was the group you played
his own intro stay fly [ __ ] right there
man yo I knew I had to come correct you
know so Rufio knows how to Rambler works
I'm respect I'm a distant Rambler how's
it going man good uh you know what yeah
I'm pretty good
that's dope I moved to Los Angeles when
it's been how long almost to you it'll
be two years in October I moved here had
a plan and the plans working you know
saying that is awesome to hear it sounds
pretty vague I could get into details
but we will we have time
so yeah you know it's dope we've known
each other for years but since you moved
to Los Angeles you have been noticeably
happier and you I mean you said it to it
I like it more out here what's just dope
your bottom by the water I'm by the
water I'm not on the water I'm by the
water I'm by the water it's a lifestyle
shift I ride my bike to the water you
ride your bike to the water I do
do you so you know that's now I just I
just pictured what one of your mornings
is like Oh some of your morning some
days you just walk out on on the beach
and just stare out for a little bit you
do those moments yeah yeah it's just
they're out like yeah it's like I don't
know what it is about the ocean but you
go there
actually I think I do know what it is is
the [ __ ] so big and powerful and you
just look out that [ __ ] and you're just
like oh all that [ __ ] that I'm
stressing about really is not as big and
as powerful as this right you know it
sounds deep and cheesy but I swear to
god it's water does that what is you
water it's really water water water
water water water water water water
water water water water water water
water
agua yeah I would that was fun but you
know what I was doing I was wishing I
knew the word for water and other
languages I only had I go out and that
was it more in Korean in Korea more mert
mert mert mert mood ice valley
mood mu l more more more more MORE
sonica we're beer but maybe when we say
water that sound like a beer sounds
Korean people maybe wait how do you say
water in French like way
awaiting what hell a gua Walt I'll help
you I like the way New Yorkers say water
yep water we say well we say water and
then other people say water well that's
like how he forty said water water water
water
I think it's toxic ah go people say that
water water water water that's a water
they say water I'm gonna get a glass of
water I say water hey let me get some
water a nice ice-cold glass of water
water water
I don't got no effects on my mic huh
word you don't I got this [ __ ] can't you
know never mind that's a whole nother
process yo I was uh you know every I do
even though we've known each other for
several years
mm-hmm I still do research and it's more
than seven years it's nine years it's
2008 Wow time flies huh FYF fest
Shawcross intake Thank You Shawn Carson
for introducing me to so many lifelong
friends from probably the worst tour
I've been on Oh a terrible tool in my
life where I met more strangers and now
I'm forever indebted to people that need
a place to crash
yeah I just can't say no to anybody
because I've stayed on too many people's
couches and floors and my my my journey
to being the musician that I am now
maybe that was the purpose of the tour
where we didn't make money but we what
we didn't make in actual money we gained
in life experience I sure learned a lot
I was I was a mess you know it was I we
I was in the Desa at the time where my
brothers Johnny and Dan who I love very
much still to this day
and we were touring and partying so hard
so many days that when we went on that
tour we were just like the worst wait
what was the ban the death said the
death said the death said what kind of
music was that it was an electronic oh
no sorry
punk-rock music that sounded like that
yeah like an Atlanta notice I like that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah sound like that going to do it
you know what whoa I didn't know where
you're going with that
with the I was trying to do that punk
rock kind of energy flow yeah that type
of flow but I couldn't lock into it okay
so good
I'm gonna take some vocal lessons that's
what i'ma do
yeah I got a vocal coach out here and it
was Kate Kate mm-hmm you you sing it now
nah you got the something she's not my
vocal coach but she is a vocal coach
he's my friend
oh okay okay nice save Rufio he didn't
want to spoil his secret R&B album is
coming out yeah release you got my vocal
coach little-known fact
you made an R&B song a long time ago
really it was called power couple power
couple yeah you were in a great
relationship at the time huh are you
really filling your girl you write a
song called power couple
so you're Europe so your main thing is
drums but you kind of do you do
everything right you're like a
Renaissance man from what I hear I'm
like what does roof you'll do it people
always say everything I don't do
everything I'm a musician you know I
play drums of my fit my first instrument
yeah so I've been playing drums since I
was like 10 years old so I'm probably
the best at that but I love music and
like I like to [ __ ] with [ __ ] like this
yeah
production yeah so I learned and I'm
still learning I'm on the journey to
becoming a great music producer gotcha
you know I was still touring with TV on
the radio I am and that's helping me be
a better music producer shout-out to
Dave siddik nice David it's like my
mentor is amazing music Purdue
nice nice nice what's the longest
session you've had man where you says
zoned out in the music sense maybe stuff
and just locked up in a studio probably
the most recent sessions I've been in
which is buddy's album we lock in for
like 12 hours a day and kind of just
cook up and create and record 20 hours
at 12 12 12 yeah you know work that off
to to that 12 hours 12 to 12 noon to
2:00 a.m. yeah 14 that's 14 hours yeah
well I mean the putt when I work on the
podcast sometimes I'll put in 12 [ __ ]
yeah master but that motive you know got
my back motus anele anele was motivation
nootropic it's a prescribed nootropic
drug but it's like a Schedule three so
it's not in the feta mean you know so it
doesn't give you all jittery and it
doesn't so you do speed everybody's up
turkeys on speed
no it just makes sure it makes sure
you're near it makes your
neurotransmitters fire quicker so I get
I get I get into it man I get what's
called again it's called modafinil
that's how you pronounce Avenue okay
okay machine all right I got so to talk
about you say cuz I think I'm funny
sometimes yeah well I only think I'm
funny cuz people like him think I'm
funny sometimes yeah like I got a couple
friends that are pretty funny for a
living you know I'm saying I'm not funny
for a living cuz I'm too scared but what
are you scared us I don't know a failure
yeah actually that is a terrifying
thought to go on in front of a bunch of
people talk and then you're trying to
get them to laugh
and they don't laugh that's always been
a fear of mine isn't that mine as if
they don't laugh and I just say this was
a speech anyway laughter but yeah you
kind of like learn tricks of saving
yourself from a bomb how you would think
after all the years I spent on Sundays
deejaying and meeting all these amazing
comics that I would have a you know and
for the regimes I don't know that Rufio
using me the og DJ for Hannibal Burres
we're hosting you the originator and
then yeah and then you know I mean and
they're not building yeah and then you
fold in at the Knitting and now you're
back and this is great now they are
friends and we're all doing good doing
pretty good yeah you know I [ __ ] my
blown up it's all good just burn it burn
it look just uh make that part into it
edible I don't know what you're supposed
to do man I'm just trying I'm just
trying to help
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
- finish
[Music]
it was also worship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that thing sounds amazing I [ __ ] love
that thing I got to bring that back into
the podcast I bought I bought one too
you did the blue joint yeah yeah you got
a pink one too I thought what is it the
looper is it the same just the same
thing in pink it's a bass Oh got you
it's an amazing instrument we got we got
Eric here who does our advertisers hire
I don't I feel like can we get it we
should get some headphones for him we
got an extra pair well I don't know it
just feels weird we're doing all these
weird noises you can't hear you can't
hear them are you just laughing you can
hear a look you can hear someone I might
get herself to to have who's heard all
the episodes over just going here all
right all right he knows what we're
doing
[Music]
oh yeah yeah hold up
how'd you get it uh link up with buddy
mmm a story so I was I was in Malibu at
a writing camp
Asher Roth and writing can mm-hmm
explain this to me what that is to write
camp um is when an artist or someone
working with an artist puts together a
bunch of people they think are dope to
make music okay so you know sometimes
it's like songwriters and producers
sometimes it's just producers you know
yeah and you go you post up out of place
usually a wall or ass place we're at
some mansion in Malibu and you rent a
bunch of gear and then you just get
drunk and smoke weed and make beats and
songs
a lot of them are pretty trashed but
some of them were freakin amazing
yeah you got a suit sighs yeah yes I was
like yeah that sounds like a really
awesome retreat yeah it's pretty dope
you guys should do a [ __ ] riding camp
we should do a writing camp I've been
thinking about Hannibal writing
basically you got an air B&B you got
some gear and then you get people decide
that for our podcast puzzles yes
basically this yeah except with uh
movies they do a punch up room yeah
we'll have they'll bring in a bunch of
writers so they'll have the script
already to have a bunch of writers work
on the script and pitch ideas and so
last year they invited me to be in the
room for the new Transformers movie ooh
like punch up stuff and so punch out
sounds violent I was unprepared but I
didn't I didn't want to do it but I
think just be a weird experience I don't
usually do these type of rooms a thing
but they asked me to come in and I get
in there the neighbors to premiere was
the day before so I had kind of a night
and I was not that prepared I didn't
make a script I was thinking that we
could do with 30 rock style where they
just put the script on a projector you
just wrote through junk by joke and you
pitch on that and know we were in the
room everybody obviously know already
small explained me and just had all
these eloquent thoughts about robots and
their motivations and [ __ ] so I'm just
about right now so why they talking is
[ __ ] I'm just trying to like skim
through the scripts so I can try to
think of something to say I'm just in
his weird nervous mo man that's what
your brain like Hannibal in a meeting
like yeah that's that's at a roll out
all right damn it
this one's [ __ ] I don't I was the
only black dude in the room like maybe
20 professional screenwriters like if
you googled them they'd be like oh
that's who wrote Terminator I didn't
know I guess that type of so your role
in that was to just like make these
lines a little funnier something get it
dark so uh everybody just must we script
but maybe they wanted me to I don't know
cuz they're not Nova writing dramas so
they probably is like you know it's so
funny what's what's a funny thing to say
before you mark somebody real fast it
wasn't like that for me that's what now
what they I'm wrong - yes you go - I'm
gonna kill you gotta unplug you mother
away I'm okay I'm gonna kill you now but
it's kind of funny that's just a long
way to say that uh yeah it's just sound
like way more fun much it wasn't like a
conference room with a hole it's so is
it was Matt Farah so so yeah so we there
I'm there with Chuck Inglish
who you guys know he's an amazing
producer that's all writer and Asher
Roth and Tim is how people there David
opportunity and Chuck invited Buddy and
Buddy was a little ass kid that we'd got
too hot and then fall asleep all day and
then wake up in the middle of the night
with all the energy in the world yeah
like what are we doing and one night I
happen to be working on a beat like
three or four in the morning he wakes up
he's like oh that's tight I'm like
alright well if you want to record some
record you know I mean yeah so we made
the song Asher got on it thanks actually
got on it later and buddy put it on like
one of his mixtapes that was a long time
ago and we just stayed friends ever
since and now he's more like family why
and a kid no kids awesome
can somebody pass the smoking no those
folks I know you feel you could pass the
beep you don't got a gumiho well maybe
speak in thanking our drinks of sweet in
Nike Asher Roth still putting [ __ ] out
is he still out there in the game I sure
I'm sure he's still he makes music all
the time but he's on a mission right now
what's that secret miss he's on a he's
on a mission to make where he comes from
Philadelphia a little bit more unified
and organized for the creatives that are
out there and kind of like helping
people figure their [ __ ] out he lives
there yeah he moved back yeah he used to
live here and he was doing his music
[ __ ] he went back home he's like yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna work with my people
at home and try to build that up you
know I mean cuz Philly which I agree has
so much talent and so so many amazing
artists away you're from no I'm I'm from
Brooklyn
oh you're from Brooklyn yeah I lived in
Philly for a little while
shoutout to all the Philly homies you
know I could do shoutouts right yeah
whatever you want
all right I shout out to Philly Philly
steak sandwiches Oh Philly cheesesteaks
yeah so um see ya
I forgot I was talking about Omaha now
you told my - Rob oh yeah he's doing
great things for the Philadelphia
community yeah all you Philly Philly
homies trying to do dope [ __ ] holla
ah sure he's a brilliant mind and he
actually cares you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in
[Music]
yo I can't drum like my dog judge me
alright
I think you're killing it no you're just
saying that you just you know what to
say I wish you wish nice things to say
what was your favorite show back Louie
will do a little factory remember the
time the RZA and Dave Chappelle showed
up and started a mosh pit and left oh
yeah wait the day they better set that
night though right yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh wait how about that yeah I've read
about Dave Chappelle starts mosh pit it
was ever I've read about this what song
was it was a rap song though that they
were just hella turn to it was a flock
[ __ ] was he flocking it could have been
that was funny Dave likes to turn up
like I was telling him a story on
another podcast like one time I was DJ
and he just kept on Hannah Montana
Hannah Montana Hannah Montana like he
loves turning up he likes I was at a
party one time and Chuck Inglish
was deejaying and dave was there and I
think he requested sprinkle me may I
meet yeah exactly the sprinkle sprinkle
[Music]
hammertime howdy
sprinkle me Mike did Chuck have it yay
dude I feel like Chuck has every raps on
his desk because sprinkling rain is a
deep cut that's uh he was put on the
spot he was put on the spot he killed it
came on I was [ __ ] I don't even remember
who was he 40
oh it's Eve 40 I just remember the hook
time and time bring up me my sprinkle me
my Serena blowing wrinkly me oh I guess
huh that's a great sound yeah so you
know all their instruments that they put
out are great oh yeah echo ha
freaking on every spear yeah there we go
yes it is all right like a freestyle -
yeah [ __ ] smooth kick in it and this
weird [ __ ] well I was doing a lot just
then I saw I was smoking the block the
smoke is burned in my nose yeah I was
playing the McRib you're a Renaissance
man I do a lot you do a lot you DJ you
produce and I play the drums
what else do you do what else you got on
I've been cooking you can you cut in
your chef
I'm chef roof several you should be
that's to be a TV show
chef roots effort like a DJ producing
cooking so different segments if you
want to write it I already got all the
other [ __ ] down locked way down cooking
and playing instruments I guess cooking
up I don't know maybe segments of
cooking and I don't know what yeah by
today we're gonna make some [ __ ] that
people like to eat what's your specialty
dish
what's your or your what's your
specialty type of food to make so I'm
Panamanian mm-hmm and I cooked like West
Indian Caribbean food
Panamanian food okay coconut rice and
peas I sell that's right your chicken
take two chicken empanadas you whatever
you're working on that food that
ethnicity of that food you make music
from that region and then you make a
dish can you do that together that's a
pretty good idea right
it seems entertaining also it seems like
a hell of a lot of work a lot of editing
life is work man love life is work but
that should be dope like you know like
they're not gonna have you guys as
guests on my show to make it you know
like some reggae I can't call it chef
roof though why not
oh that's why yeah and it sounds like
your roofing someone yeah yeah I got
that a lot favorite yeah what's your
least favorite rap name oh man I rather
not say I feel like cuz you actually got
beef with that person I will if I'll be
like your name is wack
probably I can't say there's a lot of
lacquer I think some rappers know that
it's a wack name or you think they're
not most the thing about rappers is they
got a lot of them have pretty big egos
even when they pretend to not you know
so I could think of a few names I just
think it's trash but see murder of it I
think that's a terrible one chocho see
you're talking crazy right now is that
them chasing after him hey who do what
the [ __ ] you say I'll just chop fire
good sound that's pretty cool
yeah I never liked that name see is it
seem ERDA or c-murder
I think you know murder I think you know
is murder
yeah another like that name Master P I
didn't like that name either I think
that's a great name
well mm-hmm cuz P could be a lot of dope
[ __ ]
Master [ __ ] master master player the
whole cat master Prince the whole No
Limit can't headmaster Philharmonic
mystical that's not a good word after a
mystic mr. Kao mystical so it's pretty
what about what about like modern like
current rap names that are trash whose
name do you think is wack well I was I
was just talking yesterday but is some
guy young boy never broke again that's
that's that's kind of that whole name
huh that's contact I'll see now I can't
trust you on anything constant reminder
you know from mullah what was the name
of that rapper young greatness yeah
that's a pretty wack name young
greatness come on man where the dope
names let's be positive
what are the dope names what's the dope
name like chance the rapper that's a
good name
pretty solid name nice is a good name
strong one Odyssey that's a good name
you just see I mean it's all subjective
obviously yeah for sure he's both had
we've all had different opinions about
this who is a dope rap name he's my
smokey Margiela smokey Margiela is that
a real person it's a real person where
he from New York mmm he's 14 Action
Bronson good name that's a strong name
Bobby shmurda Bobby shmurda
cousin stairs
I'd like that name is pretty good name I
just don't like lazy names like little
be like that's lazy you can't that's the
base car dog he's not saying he's bad
it's lazy to me that name little beat
you ever listen to the pack what like
sneakers yeah like sneakers I supposed
to be faster you get my pants on but
they look alike seems a pairs on but
they look like jeans cuz get my pants on
get those shorts cuz my ankles is a
different color from the rest of my body
[ __ ] [ __ ] up can't let you see that
[ __ ] so I keep the pants all
[Music]
can I get some type refers Michael
Jackson stuff for my legs I was pretty
good that was good
[Music]
what else what are you guys been up to
you guys are moving around a lot running
around a little bit I saw you guys here
a few weeks ago you play Fe FS that was
tight that was about a month ago just
about a month ago
yeah FY f fest yep I tried I tried some
[ __ ] there it didn't work how I wanted
to work work when I sent out the
impostor the guy who did the spider-man
stunt with me I sent him out and it
didn't get the is a festival that's it
that's more of a comedy club or one of
my shows mm-hmm type a bit but at the
festival I don't think it was the right
way to play it that dude was cool yeah
nice guy got a couple boos from it
though I uh I got booed I didn't get
booty he got booed my I dig at food but
I was not there to take the boat yeah is
your stunt double or whatever yeah so
you got booed no I didn't I didn't get
booed I wasn't there
Ronnie's late he was there my idea got
booed nug I got that you know saying but
yo demon yo I'm gonna tell you this in
wartime yeah it was like was it happy
booze nah it was a it was like boo boo
boo dur like scattered boos yeah like
cuz you could tell people were no like
they were they were finding they were
figuring it out at their own pace so it
was just like wait did he say something
I missed that out it was hard it was
good cingulate that stage was far from
where
was that so I had to like Trek it over
there I missed like a little bit of the
what you got to deal with security the
whole [ __ ] yeah that's that security was
tough over there there was like Fort
Knox they were they were no games it was
cuz Beyonce in them was there right
I'm Bjork beyond yeah yeah New York
yo de la so I'm gonna go you go to
somebody house and they only use sporks
you know no that's gonna be my work when
I only sporks
but like baller-ass perks but only
sports are they like plastic ones no no
like I got a Forks so you can't go fight
with - was on the hook the best part of
sports is spoon fights
you never did the whole fight is a spoon
fight it was not a Dern lunch is like
you you fold the top part of the spork
and then you use it like a hammer and
you try to break the other person's
sport Oh gotcha nah none of that [ __ ]
man 34 years old bruh no sport breaking
and all that when you a kid
yeah but kid never played cargos plastic
was there such a minimum dog we couldn't
even [ __ ] around like every plastic we
got we watch that [ __ ] we're sure the
spoon fight I've been played in a long
time but I was pretty good back in the
day must have been nice man back in the
day that's been Friday's back in the day
the spoon five days [ __ ] space it's
been Friday I had my Alma days five days
spoon five days he was the spoon five
days
days in the class phone days it's been
five days you know I've got this phone
and the spork spoons phone puts it
together with the fork that's porn fine
use a sport to eat stone fight hit you
with my spork if you are cool door to
door New York your suits short your
suits short I'm second cousins with too
short you dork Oh yo yo too short is a
real ass [ __ ] I met him and he was so
cool and so down-to-earth and made me
really proud to be a to short fan really
he's a much yeah I love to he I was like
could you hear all those all those
amazing records and you're like damn
this is a real pimp scary ass dude that
don't give a [ __ ] about [ __ ] ever I
never thought he was scared I never got
scary from him but I got serious
business from him serious business
all right fair enough but anyway he was
mad nice and I was like you're a legend
and you're mad nice and that's a lesson
you know me don't get gassed yo Rufio
what are your plans in this business man
like that night I was like yo Rufio
this [ __ ] is crazy that's right he was
like crazy we chopped it up he's like
building like a dope facility for young
producers and rappers and stuff downtown
and we talked about that told him I was
a producer that's how I was shape and it
was in a club you know I mean we had a
bottle like this bottle service kind of
close it's a man of the people
hell you not everybody's like that but
everybody should be like what you say it
was a this was an Oakland no this was
here in LA in LA yeah so he live in LA
now I would imagine so every everybody
pretty much lives here or has a house
here right nope no it's not sure is that
true can you afford a house yeah
I heard real estate market was kind of
it's pretty crazy crazy you know yeah
yeah it's pretty crazy you guys want
your house to be
I'll be living Beverly Hills or Downey
that's in a really different County that
[ __ ] is really shitty I had some bad
situations at the Embassy sweet teas Oh
wrapping your freestyle your with no B
that was like it was weird what about
this is a weird one is why I don't smoke
before the podcast man
what about like Compton you did that's
ever gonna get like gentrified and [ __ ]
you think Compton would ever become like
one of those neighborhoods uh was like
you know it's edgy South Central is
where they built the RAM Stadium so
that's starting to change I hear ya I
feel like it's possible you know like I
grew up in Bushwick in New York and I've
never thought that that area would be
gentrified I'm sayin like Brooklyn is
just it's yeah yeah it's like a big park
not very safe yeah that side of it
anyway you know was it last night you
been back to Brooklyn
I was there in April or May something
like that yeah yeah around that time
does it break your heart to see all of
that it's like it's bittersweet you know
what I mean because I feel like a lot of
resources that weren't originally there
are now there and accessible to people
but also people who have their roots
there and their family there and like
their history that kind of get pushed
out of like their home which is the
downside obviously but tell us in person
you know what I hate about it is that
you know what I hate about it is when
you when you get the people that move in
to Brooklyn and then they're just like
when is there a can't-miss Bojangles
disgusting yeah there's a lot of you
that's what that's what Warrensburg it's
like back when I used to go to like
parties it was Berg it was not like that
yeah it was not like that at all yeah
it's become it's New York yeah New York
has become mine you know we still there
was a New York institution we call it
the flat remember the flat
oh yes the flat was so crazy what's the
flat the flat was me right yep
Donnie opened a bar called the flat and
that's where we would go on Sundays
after the comedy show after did in fact
we would go over to the flat yeah
they're about 12 and it was like most
Sundays it was pretty crazy in there
wait you were you the og drummer for TV
on the radio or did you replace somebody
for a TV on the radio with did you um
well Jalil is the original drummer TV on
there yeah okay I was gonna yeah and few
years back I started playing with them
and Giglio started playing bass our
friend an amazing musician and artist
and brilliant human being Jerry
passed away and as a I was a does a deep
question that you just asked there's
like a little sorry a little deep moment
but a beautiful moment still you know
what I mean like I kind of came into the
picture when Jerry was not doing as well
and the guys asked me to audition and
then I played some shows with that
myself by Southwest and that was pretty
much supposed to be it
yeah I mean I mean the reason why I was
asking that question is because I I was
I used to date a girl that moved to
Williamsburg like 10 years ago
mm-hmm and I always see the TV on the
radio guy is always hanging out in
Williamsburg it was just like a totally
different scene back then so we were you
in that area during I was I'm a little
bit like there was like a renaissance
going on around that time 100% I was
like dabbling I was still like in the
hood and Bushwick like I was young you
know what I mean yeah I'm like the
youngest dude you know playing with
those guys so it was a little bit
different like those guys were like just
getting out of college and surrounded by
a bunch of brilliant minds amazing
artists creatives it was crazy because
I'd be walking around seeing like my
favorite band
yeah like just people from my favorite
band just doing laundry mm-hmm oh that's
do from bad whoa yeah it was a community
yeah it was like a crazy musical
Renaissance that just took over the
world yeah all of our friends pretty
much lived in the area I lived in that
area for a little while - OH
what was that like being part of that it
was amazing it was genuine it was
authentic it was people that gave a [ __ ]
about what they were doing like people
putting on our shows and raves and show
punk shows or shows and kind of just
like that's amount of creativity just
just a can a community of
amazing creatives like making their own
outlets for their art which I think
everybody should do everywhere like
there's like like if you can't find a
place to perform or do whatever you
you're trying to do just make it
yourself you know get a spot and buy
cheer people's and just do it yeah
that's what I did that's what you did
that's what everybody that does [ __ ] I
was always so jealous of that community
that you guys had to I was like you guys
was just surrounded by like the most
brilliant creative but there are other
other cities doing there too you know
Chicago Baltimore like usually around
like now our schools are back then
there's like Williamsburg was like yeah
place you'd go place for a lot of like
creatives would move to because they're
like this is where it's happen well it
was also affordable like the
neighborhood was all like industrial
like or polish or tally would you what
you did you move it mm I don't even know
it's like way later yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah that that was a special time
you know I feel like it's a lot
different now I'm not sure oh yeah it's
not it's mighty thing what happened yes
it's a lot different I think at morning
Instagram kind of made it different
household just now you can like see
everything that that's going on and it's
more like a show everybody's kind of
like in their own reality TV show and
just kind of focus more on self and like
I could just do this by myself where
before that it was like you needed a
community you needed to like you know I
don't know was that because makes sense
I do I mean it definitely I think I
don't Instagram did shift a little bit
and what I think and it wasn't as
popular back they know it wasn't they
didn't even exist back then just ideal
you know
yes seeing people with the selfies it
was it they remember it started with
like selfies is that all this is weird
like oh that person is taking a selfie
right now and now it's just like
everybody it's just like part of life
like you see somewhere taking itself you
don't even think twice about it all day
or Instagram I found out that usually we
don't feet yeah I found out the word
selfie from Twitter off of when I used
to follow the kid maro years back and
he's and it was rage day oh yeah I used
to follow maro back in the day to shout
out to them was Ray J in taken in the
hospital with his grandma is obviously
dying and he took a picture of himself
in some captions to stay strong grandma
and then maro retweeted you know Ray J
out here taking selfies with it you know
that Wow noise is it
what is that word what is what is
selfie B was invented by the Millennials
I think it was 20 yeah having a some
[ __ ] like that 22 it was you guys
remember that app back in the day he's
called the Hipstamatic it was it was
basically like the og like filters that
you can kind of oh yeah it's called the
Hipstamatic yeah oh you're talking about
yeah and I was like the Odell's before
Instagram even came out you take
pictures and then you could just put the
filters on it yeah and then they say
this is this would be a known Jeep all
right with bad lighting or something
cymatics they hit automatic I remember
it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
box naturebox
it's a snack so you saw oh yeah
naturebox
forgot them snacks eating better is hard
especially when you like snacks but
guess what nature box has awesome snacks
I'm not even lying I heard about a
hundred fifty bucks worth of snacks the
other day and sent them to my parents
house and I didn't even I just ordered
with reckless abandon just I would
jalapeno cashews and in almonds and such
and just a bunch of random stuff and my
parents have been enjoying it and they
people in their sixties so you know
people in a 60s don't just like random
[ __ ] they got very particular taste so
naturebox
got just look at going to site and look
you got to find something you like if
you don't like snacks then what type of
person are you if you don't like snacks
then I don't even want you listening to
this I don't make that much money for
this [ __ ] get out of here and guess what
guess what nature box is gonna do for
Hanson ramble of fans nature box is
offering three free snacks with your
first order when you go to nature
box.com slash Rambler that's
naturebox.com/tyler for three free
snacks with your first order do it free
snacks at your place you even got to go
to the store interact with people do it
snacks
[Music]
is now even being back in Williamsburg
though when I was just back I stayed for
two weeks which hadn't been in New York
for two straight weeks and long I'm
about to do that and it was fun and also
overwhelming and [ __ ]
it's like it's almost like shocking it's
so different it's like fun jail
it's like vice fun jail asset jail when
you very explain what what for me with
somebody that's very impulsive and has
access to everything and money to shout
out to money
bananas if you're impulsive in a free
time access and money it could get crazy
I have to chill I have to [ __ ] yeah
you throw myself you gotta consciously
you gotta consciously chill I had to be
nope we're gonna go see I know Hannibal
we're gonna go see an independent movie
by ourselves today yeah yeah I mean
that's wild like there's like never a
dull moment it's like if you can't find
something to do in New York something's
wrong with you not the city like there's
always something popping you know what I
started using recently and it was it's
been pretty helpful you Facebook has an
event Explorer section we could just see
the [ __ ] around you and it sounds like
there are new podcasts positive way I'm
saying it with such clarity that I
haven't at all podcast but I found out
you liked it let me know the underground
kind of comedy shows and [ __ ] that was
going on that cuz I don't know the new
bar shows really if I'm on if I'm in
Bushwick on a Wednesday I legitimately
what was it shows that I don't notice it
so it was real just two shows that my
friends were performing it will just
came up on Facebook exploited and I
would pop up and [ __ ] like oh that's
where show is cool I'm gonna go to
Littlefield I saw that there's a show
there
I don't is that a new thing how many use
Facebook you just pull it tutorial we'll
do it we'll put it we'll put it in post
the whole thing my hand in facebook yes
for the time lapse
yeah but that was so crazy it was such a
crazy time it was pretty crazy cuz they
would have the hip-hop night chocolate
sundaes but then you go any other nights
it could be anything going on anything
going on it would be D s I'm sure you
can go with you tattoo party some throw
in everybody
is in leather you might go in another
time people in body paint Oh different
time people in like weird furry costumes
and you go another time and it's just a
bunch of hood [ __ ] dancing the
body smart is that the one is that the
part of your tomboy where everyone was
dressed up as like anime characters yeah
yeah you texted me you said I'm at this
weird-ass anime party or some everyone's
just or something like probably the flat
if I was in New York it was probably the
flat cuz I would want I would just go to
it was it was uh yeah eight it was an
eight minute walk from my place there
was no heavy time investment it was like
late night yeah I would always was late
it was always late you know just popped
by there after shows it just had a great
white feel to it man man I was talking
to oj who used to be one of the main
promoters there I think it could
definitely be a documentary about the
flat yeah easily right just throw you
remember that telly roast yes Sally from
ninja sonic Ali from the roast that you
win in the Sonic inside I was doing my
research and then it came of an
interview of y'all may be a Central Park
[Laughter]
man shout-out to growing up and learning
and being better I think the video was
date about 2010 y'all in Central Park
oh my god a white lady came up asked
y'all for direction and I broke out of
cool character yeah you go out of there
to get me he went back to [ __ ] yo was
that success that's rapping ass [ __ ]
you know gentlemen your style so I
grabbed this for you what is that it's
uh on the rocks premium cocktails the
jalapeno pineapple margarita crisp
vibrant line smooth ones and just the
right touch of heat that sounds fine it
should look like a one of them special
juice looks like an elixir that looks
like a Hannibal drink you know I do
that's what I get fancy juices and
drinks
yeah gotta send it over there is some
palmistry I wear my long
get back on kickin it in the streets up
in Echo Park on the side that was fun
that's pretty good um wait so research
are you spying on me I just you know
spying what - by me saying this II keep
saying research I try to be somewhat of
a respectable journalist look at your
views and try to be somewhat prepared
even though I've known you for nine
years
I don't know voice disease I was doing
yeah it's like explanatory voice of
explanatory voice during when you were
talking with Just Blaze you said it's a
favorite that yeah that was amazing
that was an amazing moment and for me
personally in my life like Just Blaze is
definitely one of my top five biggest
influences and inspires and getting to
sit and talk to him was like bucket list
[ __ ]
how long did y'all talk cuz it was cut
down to about three and a half minutes
but I'm really so many it was way long
yeah we chopped it up for like 45
minutes an hour yeah at his studio it
was it was amazing he played me some
music that no one heard does he does he
smoke weed we didn't smoke weed no I
don't know probably maybe not I don't
know if the name Just Blaze I would yeah
that's for sure Just Blaze hi man you
should have that sample right here yeah
a bet here you go you got all the new
young rappers in here you need like some
producer drops
Lafleur listen respect on my name yo
ain't got the classics to you but you
need Just Blaze sir like what did you
got snoop on here you could be like just
the one of the craziest weird random
drops that we did was off a bit I have
only done probably twice when I had a I
had just gotten a tooth taken out and
then I started talking about it and then
I was like I did the bit and I was like
two things and I remember stupid there's
so many moments I remember one time with
st. Louis and I dropped the beginning of
Nellie yeah and it was like hmm
that was that was [ __ ] legendary
you're more you you are more brave on
the DJ tip because I would always be
like scared to ruin his timing or like
fuckabish the [ __ ] you doing here like
trying to play me but I'm just like just
give me the cue and I'll do it I was
taking Liberty from you just being nice
I was just having no [ __ ] given it was
just I mean we do the same [ __ ] every
Sunday you know what I mean yeah I just
started feel comfortable like yeah I'll
go there like I knew all the bartender's
they're hooking me up with Jameson
gingers yeah I was drunk and I was
dropping sound effects our shooting at
Marty's members yeah like hack hack
Weller's hecklers hecklers right yeah
yeah see I'd be like you see I never got
to do that with him so like we got right
into the theater circuit it's like I
can't be [ __ ] around
just yeah you kill you kill it though
like that I'm better in the club with
not that many people I mean it was
packed but it was like not like a giant
theater I'm like getting on the mic and
be like Hannibal coming Tuesday I'm
saying like no it's not my forte I'm
more like the technical nerd and then I
you know well actually he brought that
out of me because before I used to be
quiet around stage mmm-hmm he'd always
be like you gotta be the Asian flex I
don't deejay without a mic anymore now
it's like yeah now he's up game on
get your ass up those go let's do this I
did that at a New Year's party once and
the owners were so mad he started
talking so I was talking [ __ ] cuz it was
like [ __ ] it was like 30 seconds before
midnight and everyone was still sitting
around so I started cussing is it that
the place on Milwaukee Chicago the Betty
so it's like more of like an uppity
place like by like Soho House and all
that by like with the West Loop West
Loop where they're not it's like a nice
restaurant whatever shoutouts to my
friend Rachel she was like the chef
there she gave me big issues that you
want to spend that as I cool but these
people were being just so uptight so I
just [ __ ] I got onto my 30 seconds
before [ __ ] is wrong with New Year's
y'all [ __ ] are late y'all
dancing this [ __ ] owners house so
mad at me like I straight up the coffee
you know you got angry on the mic
cuz I was dropping them hits I was
giving them everything I know my trust
rating French red whatever you want to
be like outside of his peers thing
nobody knows I [ __ ] y'all nobody
responds I got mad and I cussed everyone
out
yeah did you still play music after that
yeah I mean I'm still playing but I
never got asked to do that gig again
what about the people that are there was
they like [ __ ] this DJ ruin my New
Year's yeah pretty much but it sucks
assuming I don't know
no gigs I dressed up I'll be doing
wedding sometimes I've got a suit I got
a black suit how are you getting that
wedding money yep yeah what's yeah I'm
like a d-list celebrity dog all the way
on the bottom of the list
do you play before I let go boom boom
[Music]
yeah if you don't to step to that [ __ ]
something wrong no choice that's an 8
that's it that's the way you test if
somebody is an alien put on Frankie
Beverly and maze before I let go if they
don't like move side to side a little
bit or do a two-step then you gotta
[ __ ] just to have them in the heart
with a steak I think at the icon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as a good cover
I wish I had a better sound you want to
switch you want to play with the drums
you know or the theremin or the drums
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
very scary
I said this how ugly
actually three Spears my eyes three cups
of coffee before I go poo yeah what do
you think you ever do like Weird Al
Yankovic like covers like that like
because that would be a good one before
I go poop that's it
yeah sure it would be fired and the key
I come up with wack parody hooks I in my
sleep
you know just no I just throw up I was
like nope but have you recorded one
professional we're in LA right now we
could do it and shoot the video you're
I'm sure I'm not doing it I come up with
these things
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the rapper's 2017 dark yo jump
yo stop looking at my shoes
once it is fresh nobody else got a bowl
and the building that's black area bags
with a separate pair of shoes for when
I'm sitting you know I get [ __ ] is
different it's all a trick I'm all like
oh [ __ ] I called the doctor take a pic
of this [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] poppin
we said you need to stop eating that
freaking late
just some fiber in your diet so festive
balls on your plate I said I i'ma try
you set your blind I said yeah I applied
to try to give the conversation over
with
you said you die that's it
[Laughter]
three cups of coffee for both you know
what I do a second cashews
times 10
grab some gum and some Cologne Cobre
[Music]
spread on me
so you can't smell me after what I've
done
super shits alone myself
[Music]
yeah we just [ __ ] kill that [ __ ] god
damn that was pure heat that was that
was I'm actually pretty impressed I mean
all I gotta do is mix and master that
that's a that's a trap
oh [ __ ] oh yeah are we doing it this
ain't no goddamn right in Kansas this is
all for TV [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah in answer
questions at the same time let's try all
right okay Shanna yes I've been waiting
for you to ask me that
yep yeah we're gonna use a natural I
don't give a [ __ ] yo bro give a [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] nope yo yeah yes let's
switch it's gonna be the on beat
interview
Oh questions simple though
alright cool night yo really yeah oh how
do I stop you TV on the radio
[Music]
yeah Rufio you said you came from a
recording session how'd it go the
session went well I didn't record [ __ ]
but I listened to stuff listen to stuff
this is the stump shade it was smooth
this [ __ ] is hard cuz I got a rat yet
I'm not a rapper I'm [ __ ] crap yeah
and try to do that [ __ ] but yo yo you
guys I'm gonna stand on feet yeah you
got it
Rufio chillin stand in the akut you know
you got it
the session was rockin how many tracks
you listen to if you have one did you
listen to that [ __ ] 10 times I listen to
the CP I'm producing is a hard word to
play on beat yeah it's the sale be wait
I listen to this EP done producing I'm
executive producing that [ __ ] I'm pretty
hype it's kind of tight look at me I'll
do it I HB hop in there ya happy now
I'm not stopping now I'm gonna stop it
now he is rocking now interview wrapping
this Bop It Now interview rapping at the
same time killing the beat though try to
talk you forget hard okay the EP you
produce so you've made all the beats
ah it's not beats no songs is that beats
mr. middle its sullen it sounds like
guitar and electronic drums yo and live
drums sounds dope [ __ ] this is hard it's
hurting my brain I feel like my eyes are
going crossed we're nice to take drum
lessons my drum instructor shout-out to
Santiago Vazquez he took me under his
wing he told me a bunch of [ __ ] yeah he
was like yo if you should be able to
talk and play a drum beat at the same
time in case you have to music direct or
communicate something to somebody while
you're in the middle of keeping the beat
Wow exactly like crazy that [ __ ] takes a
lot of [ __ ] practice he's a super
talented dude I'm like it's a lot of fun
pick you out a lot like a little party
of brain like some dip you said your
eyes were crossing with speed it was
some weird yeah it was hard I was
confused yeah he was confused but you
kept it pretty cold this is the highest
podcast we haven't done I'm surprised
I'm that done done mama done everybody
do that [ __ ] so don't give me none three
yeah this is a this is a hot one but
what you expect I smoke weed all the
time since you know me I wasn't you know
what I was just more commenting on the
situation versus
[Music]
oh my god that's so funny that was so
good however what's always in Miami and
you hired a budget you are like a Dora
the Explorer already Plus maybe a
spongebob o-genki spongebob yeah that
was one of the first that wrote
performances of it that was so funny
that was the early days of gibberish
rap' Hollis using state for a lot of
people but it was that one at the end of
my everyone never went off it's about
it's a bunch of YouTube videos up of
that one is like six or seven up of that
particular Miami performers at the stage
oh this is turn this this is the drum
set for before I go poop when the Remy's
in a system I'm kidding how freaking
Pasolini
[Music]
when the memories in a sister I'm kid
don't you dream it a good drop off handy
follow three clever dinners pay to wait
for some pennies but I'll hold the tip
[Laughter]
[Music]
one time I feel like you had a landlord
and you paid her and pennies or
something like that that was out here at
an Airbnb well she was bugging a little
bit we I threw a party was fair that
wasn't part of the rules but I did my
best to clean it up something was broken
and we had also it was a mayweather it
might have been a mayweather no it was
2012 so it wasn't made whether those
2014 seen it so it wasn't a may Pat but
uh yes he was just a petty lady and I
found the shipping shipping filming us
she liked cameras outside
of the house oh can we talk about that
after your story about people that I got
cameras in the house yes please because
that [ __ ] is weird to me that's [ __ ]
up I get that especially now you got me
looking around this [ __ ] I get
that people feel the need to protect
that place but I mean there has to be a
way to do it without being in a legal
person here's what I get you know what I
get happy maybe if you Rin if you have a
rental property having some stuff
outside so you can monitor if a bunch of
[ __ ] outside the front door
inside the crib is just it's like Big
Brother
well yeah where were the cameras place
outside Georgia 1984 [ __ ] in the
backyard not in the crib though play in
the backyard but it's a hole in a grotto
and it's a cool [ __ ]
so is they just don't want a more
focused [ __ ] and they [ __ ] there or
they want people to [ __ ] they [ __ ] no
no that's a good point and there's a
lady that she had an adopted kid she was
60s like a retired I think that well
here's the thing you can't if it's the
outdoor outside the back of the plane s
you shouldn't have that especially if
you got a pool and [ __ ] who's out there
naked and [ __ ] kicking it yeah this is
Jacuzzi yeah what I got they got you on
camera with your dick out probably TMZ
what's up holla that lady games bags a
couple years ago there's no no money in
that that lady's getting bags but wait
the 40 and the point of the story is not
Hannibal's dick on TMZ is him paying her
in quarters or something yeah I paid I
had a cinema [ __ ] to the bank to go
that's what tat you don't ask rabbit
yeah that's where I was outstanding I'll
send somebody to the bank hey there we
go
that's how I heard about Tosh robbers
being told me the story yeah just high
level so you paid somebody to go to the
bank and get you a bunch of pennies and
then cuz she was bugging me about the
cost of the fight and something else and
I think it came to a hundred dollars
total meanwhile I was paying 10 grand
for the month to live in his house and
it's saying um all right all right and
she was already paid in full so it was
my thing as it stopped bugging me about
this [ __ ] $100 I'm gonna give it to
you when I leave like you bugging me
about this like chill out
yeah it's pretty so she cares Madeline
she kept ready right that's like the
definition of petty and so petty mad
patty ER and I got the petty is text
back you know where it is come find as
you said I don't know where the [ __ ] you
at I said yeah we did in that communicat
communicate I communicated with the cat
she said what do you know about that I
said
nice one a speech chill kind of guy I
got pizza friends with no pizzas in it I
got a picture frame with no [ __ ] in
it get the spinach sautéed
it's an uber hubbub in it there's a
Corolla yeah I still get that uberx I
don't give a [ __ ]
even getting C girl I prepare checks up
in the Corolla or Honda Civic or Prius
uber X no over pulled out I don't know
who you know my nickname is not papi
chulo this papi churro
I like churros gonna get some your rows
of guy roll some grease I got two people
that you would describe as my niece what
is the real digestive time of corn-fed
beef I met with Kelly that's my favorite
[ __ ] when rappers just change words to
it they they get divorced around
communicat I mean communicate yeah great
Lil Wayne do that all the time while
they do it and you say oops
yeah oh sorry I meant my bad
you know I met that others it has a
pronounced what my bad yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can do this all night man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all highs it is up in air muhfuckas ha
don't can take an old weird-ass drinks
with you I wanna pee TT on a pair of man
I got the weird boy but I'm ranking the
boys
[Music]
[Music]
turn it not crazy on a therapist
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah this is pretty much wrote
it out dude every days ya get stoned and
play music and talk [ __ ] every day I set
for Sunday I do other [ __ ] on Sundays
this was a fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]